let's get started with this we were
initially going to start with jesse but
i think this is actually more important
context as we get into black lives
matter from the daily mail quote we are
not going to surrender to black lives
matter new york city mayor elect eric
adams warns blm leader hawk newsom not
to quote burn down the big apple and
refuses to back down on reinstating
plane clothes nypd units
it's kind of crazy when we're at a point
where a the mayor of you know the
biggest city in the country is warning
a group of leftist activists not to burn
the city down isn't it isn't it
shouldn't there be a little bit more
than that like hey you threatened to
burn the city down like that's a
terroristic threat you guys literally
did smash windows and destroy things a
year ago
maybe those threats are not idle threats
and there should be some legal
ramifications you know maybe a slap on
the wrist maybe they at least need to
come out and be like don't threaten to
burn it all down but how many times do
they say this stuff
yeah you know they say it a lot blm says
this a lot and hawk newsome also is much
further to the left i think even than
the national blm
groups and he's spoken out against the
national blm groups he's one of the ones
who was uh bringing suit against them
for
having fundraised all that money and
like nobody saw any of that money except
you know patrice culler's got a bunch of
new houses or something oh that's nice
yeah that's really nice wow well it was
just her family it was for sure she's
doing very well for herself yeah i mean
every family needs a nice little house
into pancake canyon right a couple of
them you know that's just one a few you
know a couple more like half a million
dollar houses yeah but yeah so the thing
about newsom is um he's very vigilant
about that i talked i actually talked
with him
after the um there was like a whole
incident uptown with some tourists who
were in town and they didn't want to
show their vax cards or something like
that and they ended up getting kicked
out of carmine's and then when i talked
to him about it he was like actually the
hostess was racist and used racist
language and this whole thing um but
yeah he's very vigilant against the
plainclothes cops and i want the
plainclothes cops back on the street
pulling them off the street has been a
disaster
that's how
the police know what's going on in the
community you know they're there on the
street they're involved the the context
is that uh when they defunded the police
in new york they got rid of the
anti-crime unit that's right and then
crimes skyrocketing high rocketed
murders mugging well who's getting
killed like black kids are getting
killed that's what's happening black
people are getting murdered so you know
people were shocked the the super
lefties that i know were shocked when
eric adams won the democratic primary
which essentially meant that he was
going to be mayor which he is going to
be
they all wanted maya wiley and these far
left progressives but the black
communities the conservative communities
the latino communities all wanted adams
and it's pretty clear why they wanted
him you know he was a he's from the city
he's he was a d.a
um he was a cop yeah and he was he's
definitely going to crack down on crime
in these neighborhoods and save black
lives like that's what he's going to do
i'm i'm i'm glad to hear it you know
maybe i don't agree with this guy i'm
not a fan of what the democrats have
become but if people are expressing
their support for a cop as much as i can
say you know there's a lot of things
that i don't like about the nypd the cpd
regular people saying you know what we
hate more we hate you burning down our
our businesses and throwing rocks
through our windows right this is a pie
in the face to the extremists woke left
but when they did break windows when
they did bust down businesses when they
did steal from private enterprises you
saw the police department stand back and
kind of watch everything happen you saw
some of the high command of the nypd
literally literally get on their knees
with the mayor saying we support you
guys as of course they were causing
massive
chaos massive pain for the average
citizen so you know the previous
administration acquiesced
totally to blm they they wrote their
name in front of trump's
tower and arrested anyone who dared to
express another political opinion across
that particular street so to to see this
kind of transition it's not even a major
transition it's just the guy saying hey
we're not going to have any bloodshed
we're not going to have any rioting here
i mean that should be a normal statement
it's nothing out of the ordinary and
shouldn't be
yeah i mean de blasio also did not think
that new yorkers cared about their own
quality of life and i've talked to
members of city council about this you
know who said that there are members of
city council who don't think that their
constituents care about quality of life
and anyone who lives in new york there
isn't anything else that is literally
the only thing there is there's really
expensive everything and not getting
trash in your face and stabbed when you
walk down the street so that's the
important thing and if adams can bring
some of that back
that's a good thing but i still you know
i don't just i don't agree with any of
the vax mandate stuff he's come out on
in favor of that we now have a new mask
mandate in the entire state because of
the stupid idiot garbage no one elected
her governor yes
you know
the next person's always worse right
right it's always worse that's what i'm
thinking too it's like if we get rid of
biden we have kamala and she is just
even the worst of the worst worse
she's terrible
yeah and this whole thing with the
masking now you like businesses are
going to be able to decide if you have
to wear a mask or if you have to show
your vaccine card or
whatever
let me i want to address what luke was
saying about the police because i think
there is an interesting kind of
double-edged sword here i'm not a big
fan of what the police were doing
letting people suffer but my i guess my
point is more like regular people when
they say they want eric adams they're
saying no to black lives matter and
antifa extremists and we needed people
to stand up and say something to that
now it is i think an issue when you have
a police department and you have the
whole city and this that you know the
the core democrat movement being like
abolish or defund the police well it's
no surprise that when the cops are like
we don't have the resources to deal with
this so we're not going to deal with it
you can't expect me to go out and then
put my life on the line when you will
not stand up and defend us as well right
you had in new york i think i think it
was in new york the police came out and
said we are being slammed in the media
for all of these crimes when there are
375 million police interactions and only
i think it was like nine unarmed black
men being killed or like 13 or whatever
yeah so they're the media is just
draw like drumming up all of this hate
for cops
when
99.99 of cops are just like routine
stops right most of them but you know
they also they also they also did shut
down you know private businesses in
staten island that were going against
the lockdowns the nypd is it's one of
the most funded police departments i
think in the entire world i believe
their budget correct me if i'm wrong i
think you would know this more than i
would uh libby their budget was six
billion dollars now it's five billion
dollars is that correct they did pull a
bill a billion yeah but it wasn't the
nypd shutting down restaurants in staten
island it was the sheriffs that was the
state that was under cuomo's
jurisdiction yes but it's still police
officers that came in it was but it was
not the nypd okay because the nypd if
you were walking around going to you
know basically were speakeasies during
the pandemic
uh the nypd did not come bother you at
all they brought in state troopers it
was yeah that was what was going on in
staten island that was not nypd that's
corruption
that's it's it's the these these cops
that are basically like uh attila's gym
in new jersey the local cops showed up
and the cops said something like you're
all you're in violation of you know
public ordinance that being said have a
nice day folks and they all clapped and
cheered right so what did the city do
they called outside departments to come
in and the outside cops with a smile on
their face were like i don't know you i
don't care about you screw off
callousness that that to me is like
you know what man these cops may be from
out of the community
but people need a way to like call them
out shun them for violating human rights
the the decree of an executive does not
give police the authority to do these
things
no i mean people have to stand up for
their own values and that's it turns out
that's one of the hardest things for
anybody to do
is to
have a value system make their decisions
based on that value system and to uphold
it with their with their
this is their lives every day you know
this is why i'm like you know during the
whole george floyd riots and stuff i was
kind of like in many circumstances if
the cops aren't going to defend people
who want to abolish the police i mean
good this is what people have asked for
in the cops giving it to him that being
said when then when you then get police
going to small businesses and putting
the jack boot down i'm like you want me
to defend you now not gonna happen as an
institution well in a lot of it's it's
not the police that are going around
you know enforcing these restrictions
it's individuals and business owners who
are enforcing the restrictions for the
most part new york especially yeah and
that's sort of the that's sort of the
worst case scenario i think if it was
police coming in we could all be like no
police don't do that but it's
individuals standing against other
individuals it's citizens taking up the
enforcement it's citizen middle managers
well the the difference i think is in
like new york it's most mostly the
individual restaurant owners are the
enforcers of these mandates that's right
but there still are many circumstances
in which police were engaging in this
behavior attila's jim as i mentioned the
woman who was trying to sell things on
facebook live in north jersey so we
we've seen several instances of this
and
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna come out and
defend uh you know organizations that
take the good will when when we defend
the police say defunding them is insane
if anything they need better training
better funding better programs and then
what happens they say screw the little
guy we don't care we're told to do it so
we'll do it granted as you mentioned a
lot of nypd were just like nope right
i've heard stories from people in new
york where they were like people have
you know tried calling the cops over
back you know people are free to leave
with masks and the cops just laugh yeah
they're like what do you want me to do
about it dude they're like
we're not coming out for this is
ridiculous yeah i mean my experience uh
recently in new york city uh tell me if
you're wrong maybe this was just
particularly in the neighborhood that i
was in no one's enforcing anything uh as
far as mass mandates i haven't seen any
kind of enforcement of that in local
businesses and private businesses vax
mandates no one asked me about my papers
no one asked me to put on a mask those
are the experiences that i just had a
few days ago um are you seeing the same
kind of
just not caring about any of this kind
of bureaucracy made up decrees there's a
lot of people that don't care um there's
a lot like i went to a diner the other
day
and it was like i'm not going to say
where it was because i don't want them
to get into trouble there was no issue
the vax mandates now have extended to
children so children are supposed to now
show their vaccine cards and a lot of
places are not going to enforce that
either also the mask mandate that came
down from
kathy hulkel today
is like
businesses get to decide so you can
enforce it yourself which also kind of
means like businesses that are doing
badly are they really going to stand
there and be like put on your mask or
you can't come in you know i wouldn't
i'd be like come on in please buy some
stuff
but there's been a lot of places that
are not asking for
vaccine paperwork or anything else
because they want people to come in
and also they don't care there's also
though a ton of people more than i've
seen in a long time walking around
outside with masts on
in their cars by themselves
watching cnn too much right and there's
uh the subway people are like fully
masked on the subway it'll be like i'll
be on the subway and i'll see somebody
and we'll be like oh what's up thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time